qu'est-ce que vous répondez à ce que
vous souhaitez la transparence que c'est
complètement faux et la transparence
elle existe déjà puisque Sophia chikiro
est député elle a donc déposé un dossier
auprès de la Haute Autorité de la
transparence et de la vie publique dans
lequel c'est revenu et c'est
rémunérations sont présentes et le
journal Le Monde aurait pu faire son
travail avant d'écrire des fausses
informations puisque Sophia chikiro vous
pouvez regarder les chiffres de 2017 a
touché entre 4000 et 4500 euros par mois
pendant la campagne présidentielle bon
euh
dans le même temps parce que quand même
juste pour qu'on ait des chiffres un peu
comparés dans le même temps monsieur
Griveaux qui était porte-parole
d'Emmanuel Macron touché 8000 euros par
mois non mais juste pour que tout le
monde le sache voilà donc il faut
arrêter les fausses informations je
j'invite les journalistes à faire leur
travail de vérification de manière
sérieuse par exemple la même journaliste
du Monde explique que Mathieu panot
qu'elle a président de mon groupe
parlementaire a été mise en examen c'est
complètement faux donc juste j'ai
compris qu'il y avait une volonté de
nuire mais au moins si vous préférez au
moins s'il vous plaît faites le
proprement là rien n'est est vrai dans
cet article il y a également dit il est
également dit qu'elle aurait payé des
salariés et des stagiaires qu'elle les
aurait sous-payés en tout cas au dessous
du niveau de salaire pour les
compétences on a été on a subi à 5 ans
12 perquisitions depuis 5 ans il y a
rien de nouveau aucune nouvelle
information le journal Le Monde dit il y
aurait sans doute peut-être une mise en
examen je sais pas comment il le savent
parce que en tout cas aucun d'entre nous
qui avons été mise en cause dans cette
affaire n'a été informé de ça donc je je
vous dis que
30 ans
sur ce sujet il y a eu aucune
surfacturation dans cette campagne la
campagne de on parle de la campagne
Jean-Luc Mélenchon de 2017 pour que les
gens qui nous écoutent comprennent cette
campagne et celle qui a coûté la moins
chère de ceux de l'ensemble des
candidats on nous dit oui c'était une
manière de se faire une une
trésorerie pour ensuite mais il restait
de mémoire 8000 euros à la fin de la
campagne sur ce de faire une caisse
écoutez tout ça n'est pas sérieux
mais selon l'article de rien du tout
madame puisque les records je vous l'ai
dit en réponse à ma première question
les rémunérations de ce fishko elles
sont publiques elles sont publiques donc
j'invite les journalistes qui font ce
travail à aller sur le site de la Haute
Autorité de la transparence et de la vie
publique je les aide
www.hetvp.fr ensuite vous avez un
bandeau vous pouvez faire recherche vous
tapez Sophia Chico vous allez tomber sur
un tableau où elle déclare l'ensemble de
ses revenus donc je sais pas faites
votre travail sérieusement s'il vous
plaît mettez mesdames les journalistes
aucune contestation de son rôle et de
ses pratiques au sein de la France
insoumise ça se fait à chican en tout
cas moi je ne conteste pas son rôle et
c'est pratique ça a été une une
coordinateur
inateur très important de des campagnes
présidentielles parce que j'ai bien
compris avec beaucoup de sexisme
d'ailleurs qu'on essaye de dénoncer
comme on l'a fait à Mathilde panot
comment on l'a fait à arracher le kéké
on essaye de dénoncer des femmes qui ont
un caractère qui ont une influence très
importante dans la France insoumise j'ai
trouvé ça assez oxieux il y a du sexisme
je ne dis pas que c'est juste parce que
c'est une face mais il y a une manière
de décrire j'ai vu que la magie panneau
a fait l'objet d'un article dans Le
Parisien dimanche une manière de décrire
les les femmes engagées à la France
insoumise qui ont du caractère qui se
laisse pas marcher sur les pieds d'une
manière extrêmement désagréable
[Musique]